le corbusier a fêté fêter plus tôt à
l'occasion d'une grande exposition qui
s'ouvre demain à bobo à paris le
corbusier à l'état civil s'appelait
edouard pierre jeanneret l'architecte
contemporain le plus célèbre mais aussi
le plus controversé il a construit en
france beaucoup de choses des églises
des maisons particulières des cités
ainsi à marseille la célèbre cité
radieuse c'est son nom trente cinq ans
après son inauguration que penser
habitants enquête jean pellieux et
philippe menut vue sur la mer située en
pleine ville la cité de marseille avait
tout pour réussir une maternelle sur le
toit terrasse c'est le plein air au
recreation noter aussi le gymnase dans
le même esprit des pilotis dégage de
l'espace au sol pour la promenade le
choix de le corbusier l'urbaniste le
conduisait 30 ans avant a créé
l'immeuble ville l'a fait de modules de
maisons empilés verticalement comme des
bouteilles dans un casier ce sera la
cité radieuse dans certaines rues
intérieures qui desservait les logements
des services communs notamment commerce
plusieurs couches de matériaux haddock
et toof le bruit chaque logement et en
duplex avec un escalier reliant les deux
niveaux en avance aussi pour le temps un
chauffage à air pulsé musée j'ai dû
pousser vie 37 ans que je suis la
première victime de cette maison et je
suis toujours heureuse mais maintenant
quand je suis à 6 ans et jason je
regarde autour de moi je suis toujours
émerveillé et pour vous c'est toujours
un émerveillement totale et absolument
échangé parce que j'ai pensé que les
couverts avait choisi un corps musées
étaient les bonnes couleurs
j'ai tout appris à l'architecturé un
débat ici certains n'ont pas respecté le
corbusier pour quelques mètres carrés de
plus ils ont fermé le duplex d'autres
leur loggia les aménagements les
couleurs d'un immeuble en effet n'ont
pas plu à tout le monde on la qualifie
la maison bada
sûrement les locataires de l'est pas
plus trouvé que c'était un peu spécial
qui est montée sur pilotis c'est un
petit sismique nouveaux espaces le béton
espace froid que c'était plus grande il
y avait à cette époque là n'empêche que
le syndicat en attente des dizaines de
demandes de gens qui veulent habiter la
cité radieuse
la raison le plus souvent l'esprit
différents qui règne entre les habitants
avec moi on avait visité plusieurs
appartements à marseille ayant été
véritablement séduit par le côté cinq
petites des gens l'esprit de fraternité
entre ed
et puis aussi il ya beaucoup de
d'activités pour les enfants beaucoup
d'équipements collectifs l'entousiasme
des occupants ne doit pas occulter le
scepticisme de certains le corbusier
concevaient la cité pour les masses or
ce sont des cadres qui l'habitent
de son vivant le corbusier fut ami ou
adulé l'histoire ne retiendra peut-être
demain de le corbusier que le nom d'un
homme en avance sur son temps